back in this country and a call with
president zielinski president biden said
america is ramping up its military aid
to ukraine with another 800 million
dollars of equipment
and for the first time the u.s will be
sending heavy artillery to the ukrainian
military along with more javelin
anti-tank missiles and other types of
weaponry david martin got an exclusive
look at a shipment of javelins headed
from this country to ukraine
500 javelin anti-tank missiles are
included in the latest round of military
aid approved by president biden
the javelins which are proving the
single most effective weapon against
russian tanks
arrive in unmarked trucks at dover air
force base in delaware
which is the hub of resupply flights for
ukraine there are 24 javelins in each
stack
several hundred in all
once they're all loaded on this 747 it's
a seven hour 52 minute flight to poland
where they will all be turned over to
the ukrainian military
moving supplies through a giant
amazon-like warehouse at dover
the u.s is one of 15 countries sending
military aid to ukraine in an operation
run out of germany by the european
command's chief logistics officer
how much have you moved so far
we have moved almost 400 aircraft across
u.s and our allies on a daily basis
how many flights are going into these
countries on the border with ukraine
between eight and ten flights a day and
that's from approximately five to seven
donating countries
the javelins combined with the skill and
bravery of ukrainian soldiers to win the
battle for kiev
but now the russians are massing their
forces for a bigger battle in the east
of the country
the u.s will now start rushing bigger
more expensive equipment to the front
including artillery pieces along with 40
000 shells and armored personnel
carriers even russian-made helicopters
we are in it to win it's the top
priority how long can you keep this up
we can keep it up for as long as it
takes
the ukrainians do not know how to use
all of the american-made
equipment included in this latest round
of eight so the u.s will have to start a
training program to teach them but with
this major battle looming in the east
it will have to be a crash course gail
all right they seem ready to learn thank
you very much david